du monde sait ce que je retrouve sur new
super mario bros 3 et vous allez voir
que ce n'est pas vraiment le super mario
bros 3 c'est en fait un jeu qui a été
quelques peu remixé comme on les aime ou
pas du tout aller c'est parti alors de
ses crocs chinois je ne comprends
absolument rien ok donc c'est si c'est
une superbe intro chinois on va
absolument rien comprendre à est ce que
ce n'est qu'un parmi nous peut-être bien
lui qui fait qu avait avait à ok donc
désormais sonné mesure 40 cm bon ben
voilà enfin sur le jeu au rôle direct
dans le jeu mais a tant vécu quelques
tech fait pas nous sommes même sur 1 m
ils ont mis trois pièges jolie bagarre
alors ça fait moins mal à à caen hommes
et non mais mai au caire d'autres pado
tâche majeure lorsqu'il a écrit dessus
soit ya écrit ici de mise en sécurité
mon enfant soyez écrit tu vas bon
respect des transferts je propose de
s'auto tue pas d'eau c'était donc un
piège aux phoques est sérieuse mais
c'est sérieux le rocket tuyaux en plus
faut que tout se retaper 8 ha d'arbres
ou
plus forte encore l'explosion en tout
cas j'ai pas eu assez mal aux oreilles
oh oh oh mec sort de nulle part
j'ai un bon buzz les trucs comme ça
est ce que c'est une tentative de
séduction tient bien arrête bon qu'est
ce qu'on fait ce qu'on voit sur le tuyau
ou dans le tuyau
non mais parce que là j'étais mal
installé donc je peux pas bien me
concentrer et tous ok on fait quoi avec
ce [ __ ] de merde mais comment mais non
ça on se sent le jeu qui était codé
quand même avec heures avec la tête n'en
fait pas le jeu sera presque bon dollars
il est vraiment traître mais non mais
c'est quoi ça c'est hiroshima d' homme
voilà tient t-bag t-bag un vieux pick ça
vous énerve à caen vous résiste 1 va
t'acheter des lieux des lettres mais
c'est pas gentil ce tube waka du moins
comme ça à huawei à j croyait tellement
pas c'était le cri du désespoir mais mec
maintenant allez vous faire
j'ai pas vu il ya un travesti à la
fenêtre en fait avec avec une perruque
blonde qui se tape un kiff là qui aime
bien voir mourir et voilà c'est lui
c'est lui qui est la télécommande de
l'arbre je le vois regardez bien et
c'était vraiment pas truqués en plus à
les ont pas je m'en vais les il me
laisse même pas prendre la fuite
what c'était quoi ce gravi mario le
nouveau film très impressionnant
disponibles au cinéma dès maintenant la
fois les deux dans folle est dedans
c'est quoi ça un trou noir mais
n'auraient fait tard je pensais que
j'allais sauter dedans mais ça c'est pas
normal ça à mes doudous il est apparu
comme sa façon c'est comme si moi je
faisais ça ça lui le mec ça va et
pourquoi se travestit est encore là haut
trop de questions trop de questions
bruce explose de co loeb fait vingt maïs
il se cache dans trente centimètres de
terre ok maintenant faire quoi faites
juste faire la flèche du haut ok ça sent
mauvais il ya plein de plantes attendait
c'est un tournesol depuis qu à tournesol
ses offensives
normalement ils cherchent juste le
soleil comme ça au soleil ou oui tu me
viennent hulot il faut pas sa [ __ ]
c'était quoi ça va bien j'ai rien
compris mais non mais ça fait peur mais
arrêter quoi bon je vais remplacer tous
les bruits d'explosion par les
miaulements parce que là ça suffit
hd est une idée non c'est non c'est
cette danse va ça mon idée mais non mais
laisse moi avec
on y est oui attention c'est la suite de
l'histoire incroyable histoire que on ne
peut pas suivre des corps dont kaka fait
mumuse avec son tipp-ex et lieu chez
mario sont en extase devant cet
amusement et on se retrouve là
avec ce [ __ ] d'arbres non il est
éveillé à faux ah mais oui d'où il est
sorti il a attendu une heure et demie
avant de préparer ce coup là [ __ ] mais
non mais l'armée arrête arrête niveau 4
je serais déçu rockets up tard le petit
truc dans l'ombre lac a juste fait
bonjour je viens te tuer c'est quoi ça
olic rousteing mais comme plateforme de
transport tu t'étais comme accroché à l
[ __ ] faut pas marcher en pourboires si
je ne peux plus je n'arrive plus au
hockey faut avancer même temps qu'elle
voilà comme ça mes mecs mais non mais
c'est scandaleux ce jeu incroyable quoi
ah [ __ ] l'autre pas nos bêtes
il fait des reprises de volée carrément
il me voit sauter il fait un plat dégage
un fils de chien allez je retombe dans
le membre
oui mon gars oh oui atteint le pic non
oui oui j'arrive à m'en je vais je
mettre la table tout de suite
ok faut avancer sauter non je ne pouvais
je fais ça imitation d'une machine à
laver
ok ok ok un peu et oui bon ah je me
savais non mais ça là il ya combien de
pièges à la même et je veux retourner au
niveau d'avant laissez moi à le il a
attendu que son camarade face diversion
pour enfin bref voilà
au regard on est arrivé à un stade
tellement impressionnant vous la
pression est présente
ap voilà un butin mais à chaque fois il
a tu sais pas pourquoi ils arrivent mais
puisque je suis là il est à
non oui oui regardez mal et nous
félicitent hockey yoshi arrive par
derrière avec son nez de 20 cm oh mon
dieu oh mon dieu oh mon dieu à quelqu'un
jouer avec un type experts cette fois
bon là on atteint à peu près 10 pièges
par m ce qui devient carrément injouable
au regard des moyens non de pêche
cueillir au machin le pic le tout cela
fleure ça y est cela fait 1
on s'amuse oh mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça mais oh mais c'est la boisson de
mais beck ya 800 pique un arbre non mais
oh oui doit aller trois autres
[Musique]
oui oui oui je m'envole oui oh oui oh
mon dieu c'est que ça et maintenant cour
a dû alors non mais c'est une énorme
boulette c'est juste ce niveau voilà des
sortes de piques qui me suivent au bon
dieu mais mais que cela importe quoi il
saute dans le nuage et meurt
[Musique]
non mais là et là c'est trop haut
pourquoi pourquoi c'est ahmed vers la
gauche voilà là c'est la mort assurée
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça et c'est
transformé en sting le t-bond mes
voisines on met la sonata stade qui
n'est plus possible je ne conçois plus
j'arrête tout de suite cet
enregistrement tac aller cordialement la
direction joue à ce jeu craquer votre
slip en course taper tout ce qui vous
passe sous le nez par exemple soutient
aussi le cas c'est avec la tête quand
allemand un pis aller
[Musique]